in the movie Mavericks that was the surf
movie yeah yeah did you almost drown on
that movie or something I read I did
yeah you actually had a surf for the
movie I had to Surf and and it was my
dream to actually go and surf that wave
even though the movie is all about you
know just that people have no idea how
dangerous and how much training and and
what and what what what metal it takes
to go had you ever surf before that I
just learned I wasn't even that good but
I knew what I learned to actually learn
to serve big waves before small ones
because I knew if I can be towed in I
learned to toe in because it's hard to
get up on a board you're lying on the
board they pull you and then you got to
stand up you've got to get on the board
where you're going and then they've got
to do it in perfect time so that you
catch the waves you know is it so in
other words they give you an assist
because this is a high difficulty uh
thing they're hard to to paddle into and
I thought if they can just get a few
seconds of me on that big wave I said if
I could just go out there and serve
Maverick so I personally because they're
like listen if you get caught in
Mavericks there's nothing we can do we
can't go in because the waves are too
big we've got to wait for them to pass
that might be 12 waves that's three or
four minutes you're done so if you
didn't know how to surf at all could
they have just faked it and used the
body double and then been done with it
or did you in order to get the part you
needed to know how to serve no no I mean
they they offered it to me and said they
said well the movie's not going to
happen if you don't do it so they said
so you do whatever you want if you can
surf a bit if you can surf a lot if you
can't even serve we'll we'll work
something out wow so but you know the
thing is it's just the difference it's
the subtle difference you want to see
that you want to do it and if you see
the guy doing it it's the same in a
fight sequence if you know it's him if
you have to do you know Quick Cuts if
it's a body double and it's just not the
same so I wanted to do it but it was
that's not when the accident happened it
was the next week and we were doing a
part where we're paddling out and it's
the first time that the kid who's you
know Jay
um played by I Johnny he's watched he's
watching me paddling out and it's the
first time he's seen Mavericks and it's
awesome
so we're paddling out and these huge
waves are coming in you're trying to get
over the top we were in the worst
position and this wave start we saw half
a mile away and suddenly even as I'm
talking about it you get those
butterflies in your stomach because the
guy goes bottle Jerry battle battle and
you start paddling and you're piling and
and you're you're paddling about 70
yards to try and get out of the way of
this wave and it's getting bigger and
it's getting bigger it's the size of
like a three-story building right and
then and then you realize you've taken a
gamble because now you're exhausted and
the way it's going to hit you and you're
going down and I went down and I just
didn't seem to come back up and I'm like
why am I because when you die well
because because it's at the end of the
week because we were so deep there's so
much gas in the water that literally the
it's the white water is about five foot
you can't you're not coming up pushes
you down you just don't rise above it
plus I'm spending spinning spinning and
then I realize it's ripped my board off
me so I'm not I'm not being pulled up
and I'm out of breath I'm literally
I'm going this is horrible a nan the
next wave comes so I didn't even get up
to the top so then I knew did you think
you're gonna die then I started thinking
either I was going to die or that they
would hopefully find me and and revive
me well after I came out of the water
um he filmed me even even though I'd
almost drunk and I'm like and my head
was ex I thought my head was good they
use that in the in the film no they
didn't use it in the film because it
wasn't really so I'm supposed to be
waste I'm supposed to be a good surfer
in the film wow so uh Grant was on a jet
ski and to see him he's guys six foot
five he's Invincible to see him looking
at me he was terrified and I knew I'm in
trouble and he couldn't get to me I went
down again wow I came back up then there
was nobody there I went down again and
then when I came back up they grabbed me
but when he was pulling me the next wave
was coming and I'm now right at the
rocks and when these waves hit these
rocks they go 50 feet the air They smash
it so they had to get me out the way but
the water's now going over my face
because he's holding my hand pulling me
and I knew if I let go I'm dead but I
can't breathe still because the water is
going over my head so and that was about
a good 200 yards pulling me around the
site imagine dying for that movie you
know like that's so crazy that'd die for
a movie that's what I started thinking
is it went from okay this has become a
story you know amongst us then I'm
thinking oh my God this is now becoming
a disaster like they're gonna right you
know and there are dudes that die on
movies you went with these action films
they're asking you to do more and more
crazy stuff yeah you don't know what the
hell's gonna happen you don't know
foreign